This is part 2 of the Frankston serial killer. If you haven't listened to part 1 yet, please go back and do so before continuing. We left last week just after the body of Natalie Russell was found, the third victim of the Frankston serial killer. And police had the registered owner's details of a suspicious vehicle that was seen on Sky Road at the time of Natalie's murder. Detectives were in a check and found that the vehicle belonged to a man by the name of Paul Charles Denier.
这是弗兰克斯顿连环杀手案的第二部分。如果你还没有听过第一部分，请在继续之前先去听一下。上周我们讲到娜塔莉·拉塞尔的尸体被发现，她是弗兰克斯顿连环杀手案的第三名受害者。警方当时已经掌握了一辆可疑车辆的登记车主信息，该车在娜塔莉遇害时曾出现在天空路。侦探们进行了核查，发现这辆车属于一个名叫保罗·查尔斯·丹尼尔的男子。
They saw Paul and his car had been checked out before too. He had recently been spoken to by police sitting in his car alone at night in a nearby car park. Paul Denier was born on the 14th of April 1972, making him 21 years old at the time. He had four brothers and one sister. Paul was the middle child. Paul was average looking, overweight with a baby face, clean cut and was quietly spoken. He basically looked the total opposite of what you would expect a serial killer to look like.
他们发现保罗和他的车之前也曾被调查过。警方最近曾与他谈过话，当时他独自一人在深夜坐在车里，停在附近的一个停车场。保罗·丹尼尔出生于1972年4月14日，案发时他21岁。他有四个兄弟和一个姐妹，保罗是中间的孩子。保罗长相普通，超重，长着一张娃娃脸，打扮整洁，说话声音很轻。他看起来完全不像你心目中连环杀手的样子。
His parents were Anthony and Maureen Denier. They moved to Australia from the United Kingdom in 1965. They lived in Sydney and Adelaide before settling in Melbourne. Paul didn't mix well with the other kids at school. He struggled academically, had low self esteem and other kids tended to stay away from him, leaving him isolated. From a young age he displayed a complete lack of emotion about pretty much everything. When he was 11 years old he cut the throat of his sister's teddy bear.
他的父母是安东尼和莫琳·丹尼尔。他们于1965年从英国移居澳大利亚。他们在悉尼和阿德莱德住过，之后定居墨尔本。保罗在学校里与同学相处得不好。他学习困难，自尊心低，其他孩子往往对他敬而远之，使他陷入孤立。他从小就表现出对几乎所有事情都完全缺乏情感。11岁时，他割开了他妹妹泰迪熊的喉咙。
When confronted about it, he just smirked. Around that time the family's cat was found hanging in a tree with its throat cut. Paul blamed the neighbours, but his older brother noticed the blood on Paul's pocketknife. At 13 he was arrested for stealing a car. He ended up getting a caution for that because he was a juvenile. At 15 he was charged with assault on a fellow student. He was also caught staring through the window at one of his brother's girlfriends who was undressing. Paul worked a number of manual jobs.
当被质问时，他只是冷笑。大约在那个时候，家里的猫被发现吊在树上，喉咙被割开了。保罗把责任推给邻居，但他哥哥注意到了保罗折叠刀上的血迹。13岁时，他因偷车被捕。因为他是未成年人，最终只得到了一个警告。15岁时，他因袭击同学被指控。他还被抓到透过窗户偷看他哥哥的女朋友换衣服。保罗做过很多体力活。
He was sacked from all of them for either dishonesty or for being lazy. He had an interest in knives and he liked going out on long walks by himself in the middle of the night. He met his girlfriend Sharon Johnson while working at a grocery store, one of the seven jobs he was sacked from. Sharon was described as being very controlling, demanding to know where he was at all times. Paul was said to be well and truly under Sharon's thumb. Sharon was opinionated and often rude in the outspoken. Paul was generally more reserved and softly spoken.
他因为不诚实或懒惰被所有工作单位解雇。他对比刀具很感兴趣，喜欢在深夜独自一人长途散步。他在一家杂货店工作时认识了他的女朋友莎伦·约翰逊，那是他被解雇的七份工作之一。莎伦被描述为控制欲极强，要求随时知道他在哪里。据说保罗完全被莎伦掌控。莎伦很有主见，说话往往粗鲁且直率。保罗通常比较内向，说话轻声细语。
He had very few friends, it was just Sharon and his family that he mainly associated with. Paul applied to join the police force in early 1993. He failed the physical due to being overweight. He knew the Frankston area well, having lived there most of his life. He spent a lot of time in his teenage years smoking marijuana with his brothers at both Lloyd Park where Elizabeth Stevens was found, and along Taylor's Road where Debbie Freem was found. Detectives paid Paul a visit at his Frankston North unit in the afternoon of the 31st of July, 1993, the day after Natalie Russell was killed.
他几乎没有朋友，主要只和莎伦以及家人来往。保罗在1993年初申请加入警队。由于超重，他没能通过体能测试。他很了解弗兰克斯顿地区，因为他大半辈子都住在那儿。他青少年时期花了很多时间与兄弟们在劳埃德公园（伊丽莎白·史蒂文斯被发现的地方）以及泰勒路（黛比·弗里姆被发现的地方）吸食大麻。1993年7月31日下午，也就是娜塔莉·拉塞尔遇害的第二天，侦探们拜访了保罗在弗兰克斯顿北区的住所。
Paul was at home with his girlfriend Sharon. They invited the detectives inside their small, messy and barely furnished unit. They asked all of the usual background questions, then got down to business, asking Paul what he had done and where he had been the day before. Paul explained that he woke up about 7.30am. He drove Sharon to work, then went to an ATM in Seaford and withdrew $40. He then drove around to a few car wreckers to try and find a spare wheel for his old Toyota. He found one, returned home, worked on his car for a bit,
保罗当时和女朋友莎伦在家。他们邀请侦探进入他们狭小、凌乱且几乎没有家具的住所。侦探问了所有常规的背景问题，然后进入正题，询问保罗前一天做了什么，去了哪里。保罗解释说，他早上7点半左右醒来。他开车送莎伦去上班，然后去西福德的一台自动取款机取了40美元。接着他开车去了几家汽车拆解场，想为他的旧丰田车找一个备用轮胎。他找到了一个，回到家，修了一会儿车，
then went to a different car wreckers to try and find a new speedo cable. He called in to visit his mother while he was out, but she wasn't home, so he had a coffee with her boyfriend. While he was out on this journey, his car overheated, so he had to pull over. He topped the water up and went for a quick walk while waiting for the radiator to cool down. He started the car, but a short distance later it overheated again. He pulled over on Sky Road, checked under the bonnet and noticed a hose had come loose. He needed a screwdriver, so he closed the bonnet and walked home to get one, also filling his water bottles up so he could top up the radiator again.
然后去了另一家汽车拆解场，想找一根新的速度表线。他在外面时顺便去看了看他母亲，但她不在家，所以他和她男朋友喝了杯咖啡。在他这次行程中，他的车过热了，所以他不得不靠边停车。他加了水，在等待散热器冷却时去散了会儿步。他发动了车，但没开多远又过热了。他在天空路靠边停车，检查了引擎盖下，发现一根软管松了。他需要一把螺丝刀，所以他关上引擎盖，走回家去拿，顺便把水瓶装满，以便再次给散热器加水。
That was his explanation for being on Sky Road. Detectives wanted to know why he didn't knock on one of the doors of the nearby houses to see if he could borrow a screwdriver and use their water. Paul replied, I don't like going into other people's houses. The detectives then wanted to know why he didn't go to the nearby golf course. Paul replied, I didn't think of that. Paul then explained the numerous scratches and the larger, deeper cuts on his middle finger and thumb were caused by all the work he was doing on his car the day before.
这就是他出现在天空路的解释。侦探想知道为什么他不敲附近房子的门，看看能不能借把螺丝刀并用他们的水。保罗回答说：“我不喜欢进别人的房子。”侦探接着想知道为什么他不去附近的高尔夫球场。保罗回答说：“我没想到。”保罗随后解释说，他中指和拇指上的多处划痕和较深较长的伤口，是因为他前一天修车时造成的。
Detectives then wanted to know what Paul was doing three weeks earlier, the night Debbie Freem disappeared. Paul surprised them when he remembered specifically that it was a Thursday night and when he put himself at Cana Nook train station just around the corner from where Debbie Freem disappeared. Paul had just placed himself at the scene of two murders. Instead of questioning detectives and being suspicious as to why they were there asking him all these questions, he sat back casually and answered them all, almost as if he was enjoying what was going on. He was calm and relaxed, barely batting an eyelid. Paul agreed to go to the police station for a more formal interview.
侦探接着想知道保罗三周前在做什么，也就是黛比·弗里姆失踪的那天晚上。保罗让他们感到惊讶的是，他清楚地记得那是一个周四晚上，并且说他当时就在离黛比·弗里姆失踪地点不远的卡纳努克火车站。保罗刚刚把自己置于两起谋杀案的现场。他没有质疑侦探，也没有怀疑他们为什么要问这些问题，而是随意地靠在椅子上回答了所有问题，好像很享受这一切。他冷静而放松，几乎连眼皮都没眨一下。保罗同意去警察局接受更正式的询问。
He was taken to Frankston Police Station where he was interviewed by Sergeant Rod Wilson and Senior Constable Mark Wolf from the Homicide Squad. The interview commenced at 9.20pm on Saturday the 31st of July. It was recorded on video. They advised him he didn't have to say anything and that he also had the right to speak to a lawyer. Paul said he didn't want to exercise either right, he was happy to talk. Paul continuing, I must inform you that you're not obliged to say or do anything, but anything you say or do may be given an evidence. Do you understand that? Yeah.
他被带到弗兰克斯顿警察局，由凶杀组的罗德·威尔逊警长和马克·沃尔夫高级警员进行询问。询问于7月31日星期六晚上9点20分开始。询问过程有录像。他们告知他，他不必说任何话，也有权要求律师。保罗说他不想行使这两项权利，他很乐意交谈。保罗继续说：“我必须通知你，你没有义务说或做任何事，但你所说或所做的任何事都可能成为证据。你明白吗？”“明白。”
What is your age and date of birth? I'm 21 years old, I was born on the 14th of April 1972. Okay, are you an Australian citizen? Yep. Are you currently employed? No, I'm unemployed at the present time. All we'd like to do, Paul, is if you can just run through starting with yesterday morning. I got up in the morning about 20 to 8, 7, 30, 20 to 8 and there's some wires.
“你多大？出生日期是什么？”“我21岁，出生于1972年4月14日。”“好的，你是澳大利亚公民吗？”“是的。”“你目前有工作吗？”“没有，我现在失业。”“保罗，我们想做的是，你能从昨天早上开始讲一遍吗？”“我早上大概7点40分，7点半，7点40分起床，然后有一些电线……”
They painstakingly went back over the story he had given them back in his unit. Detectives went over every detail. There were contradictions and times weren't matching up. The explanation he was giving for his injuries wasn't making much sense either. As I was coming down, say past Karimov Drive, my neighbour's temperature gauge started to go right up to high. So I just pulled over the inside road and right across the road, you know, golf course and everything. So I pulled up there and I checked under the car under the bottom and found out the hose could come loose. When we saw you down at your flat this afternoon, I noticed a number of cuts on your fingers.
他们不厌其烦地回顾了他之前在住所里讲的故事。侦探们核对了每一个细节。其中存在矛盾，时间也对不上。他对自己伤口的解释也说不通。“当我开车下来，比如说经过卡里莫夫大道时，我邻居的温度表开始升到最高。所以我把车停在内侧道路上，就在马路对面，你知道，高尔夫球场什么的。所以我停在那里，检查了车底，发现软管松了。”“今天下午我们在你公寓见到你时，我注意到你手指上有几处伤口。”
Can you just put your hands right on the desk here so that it can just right up here? This injury here is a long sort of a cut. Just explain how you got that injury and when you got that injury. I got it yesterday and I was working on the car. How are you saying it occurred? Well, the fan spins this way. So if I'm standing in front of the car, like here, the fan spins that way, the alternator sits there. And there's wires running down underneath the bottom of the radiator.
“你能把手放在桌子上吗？就在这儿。这个伤口是一道很长的划痕。解释一下你是怎么受的伤，什么时候受的伤。”“我昨天修车时弄的。”“你是怎么说它发生的？”“嗯，风扇是这样转的。如果我站在车前，就像这样，发电机在那儿。电线从散热器底部下面穿过。”
There's a wire at the top, which was for a wire that I just recently put on. And that's what it means when I put my hand down there, I caught the fan. Why did you have it running at that stage when you were checking the radiator? Time for the workout on class. Detectives asked him more questions about Debbie Freem. Paul stuck with his story, putting himself at Cannonook train station roughly at the same time and just around the corner from where Debbie went missing. Not only that, it was the one night Paul failed to pick his girlfriend Sharon up from work.
“上面有一根电线，是我最近刚装的。这就是我把手伸下去时，被风扇刮到的原因。”“你检查散热器时，为什么让它转着？”“修车的时间……”侦探问了他更多关于黛比·弗里姆的问题。保罗坚持他的说法，把自己放在了卡纳努克火车站，时间大约是黛比失踪的时候，地点就在她失踪地点的拐角处。不仅如此，那天晚上保罗正好没去接女朋友莎伦下班。
Amazingly, on the night Elizabeth Stevens was murdered, he told detectives he was out walking in the rain. He walked from his place to his mum's place, then to Sharon's mum's place. He says he was looking for a spare car battery. The area he was walking, Elaine Warren, right near Lloyd Park. Instead of giving himself an alibi, all he was doing was placing himself at the scene of each murder. Yesterday, your car was parked opposite the location where the body of Natalie Russell was found. On the night that Debbie Freem disappeared, you walked over to Cannonook railway station, missed the train and walked back.
令人惊讶的是，在伊丽莎白·史蒂文斯被谋杀的那天晚上，他告诉侦探他当时在雨中散步。他从自己住处走到他妈妈家，然后走到莎伦妈妈家。他说他在找一个备用汽车电池。他散步的区域，伊莱恩·沃伦，就在劳埃德公园附近。他不仅没有给自己提供不在场证明，反而把自己置于每起谋杀案的现场。“昨天，你的车停在发现娜塔莉·拉塞尔尸体的地点对面。在黛比·弗里姆失踪的那天晚上，你走到卡纳努克火车站，错过了火车，然后走回来。”
And on the night Elizabeth Stevens disappeared, you walked in a very close proximity to Lloyd Park on your way to pick up this battery. Do you think that's fairly coincidental though, in all the circumstances? Are you responsible for the deaths of any of these women? No. When they asked him specifically about Natalie Russell's murder, Paul denied having anything to do with it. But he said he was aware of what happened because he drove past the scene. Are you aware that a girl was found murdered in Frankston?
“而在伊丽莎白·史蒂文斯失踪的那天晚上，你在去取电池的路上，走到了离劳埃德公园非常近的地方。你觉得在所有这些情况下，这纯属巧合吗？你对这些女性的死亡负责吗？”“没有。”当他们具体问到娜塔莉·拉塞尔的谋杀案时，保罗否认与此有关。但他表示他知道发生了什么，因为他开车经过了现场。“你知道有个女孩在弗兰克斯顿被谋杀了吗？”
Yeah. Today being Saturday. Yeah. When did you first become aware of that? Well, I oversaw some police cars and everything when I was driving up Sky Road this morning, and SES workers. So you saw SES workers and all that in Sky Road? Yeah.
“知道。”“今天是星期六。”“是的。”“你是什么时候第一次知道这件事的？”“嗯，我今天早上开车上天空路时，看到了一些警车什么的，还有紧急服务人员。”“所以你看到了紧急服务人员和那些在天空路的人？”“是的。”
And I had some white tape across the walkway. Who were you? You saw who you saw mate? Yeah, I saw you. And I saw the other guy. And that was what were you doing when you saw that? Or were you going or what were you doing? Oh, we were going to the wreckers.
“还有一些白色的胶带横在人行道上。”“你是谁？你看到了谁，伙计？”“是的，我看到了你。我还看到了另一个人。”“当你看到这些时，你在做什么？或者你要去哪儿，或者你在做什么？”“哦，我们要去拆解场。”
He was then asked if he knew anything about the victims personally or how they died. Paul replied. Yeah, Elizabeth Stevens had a throat cut, and the other girl Debbie Freem had multiple stab wounds or something to her body and upper body. Up here. Paul pointed to the exact spot where Debbie's wounds were. Detective Wilson pounced. Why did you indicate the exact area?
随后他被问到是否私下认识受害者，或者知道她们是怎么死的。保罗回答说：“知道，伊丽莎白·史蒂文斯的喉咙被割开了，另一个女孩黛比·弗里姆的身体和上半身有多处刺伤。就在这儿。”保罗指着黛比伤口的准确位置。威尔逊侦探猛地抓住机会。“你为什么指出准确的区域？”
I was just pointing, that's all. But why did you point there? It was just a lucky guess. When detectives asked if he would provide his fingerprints and a sample of his blood and hair, Paul agreed. But he started to look very uncomfortable. Detectives paused the interview for a coffee break and to wait for an officer to come and take his hair and blood samples.
“我只是随便指指，仅此而已。”“但你为什么指那里？”“只是瞎猜的。”当侦探询问他是否愿意提供指纹以及血液和头发样本时，保罗同意了。但他开始显得非常不自在。侦探暂停了询问，休息喝咖啡，并等待警官来采集他的头发和血液样本。
Well, we just had to spend the interview for a short time. Do you have anything else you want, like a cup of coffee or a glass of water? Yeah, I'd like another cup of coffee. Any heavy coffee? I'd like two. All right, I'll get you a cup of coffee, all right? Just a short break. During the break, Paul went to the toilet.
“好吧，我们得暂停一下询问。你还需要什么吗，比如一杯咖啡或一杯水？”“是的，我想要另一杯咖啡。”“还要咖啡吗？”“我想要两杯。”“好的，我会给你拿杯咖啡，好吗？休息一会儿。”休息期间，保罗去了洗手间。
The officer who escorted him to the toilet was Detective Darren O'Lachlan. Paul saw that O'Lachlan was wearing a cross and he started to ask him about religion. The conversation then moved to DNA. Paul wanted to know why they wanted his blood and hair. Had they found something at the scene? And if they had, how long would it take to match? O'Lachlan said he couldn't answer any of those questions. He would have to check with Detective Wilson.
护送他去洗手间的警官是达伦·奥拉克兰侦探。保罗看到奥拉克兰戴着十字架，便开始问他关于宗教的问题。谈话随后转到了DNA。保罗想知道他们为什么要他的血液和头发。他们是在现场发现了什么吗？如果发现了，匹配需要多长时间？奥拉克兰说他无法回答这些问题。他必须去问威尔逊侦探。
Paul was silent for a short period of time before looking at O'Lachlan and saying, Okay, I killed all three of them. O'Lachlan immediately alerted Detective Wilson and the interview was started again. This time, O'Lachlan sat in on the interview as Paul seemed to take a liking to him. Some of the audio clips you're about to hear are taken from the interview and some are taken from a walkthrough of the crime scenes that was done after the interview. First, they talked about the murder of Elizabeth Stevens. You spoke to Detective O'Lachlan here and you were told, Detective O'Lachlan,
保罗沉默了一会儿，然后看着奥拉克兰说：“好吧，这三个人都是我杀的。”奥拉克兰立即通知了威尔逊侦探，询问重新开始。这一次，奥拉克兰旁听了询问，因为保罗似乎对他很有好感。你即将听到的一些音频片段摘自询问过程，另一些摘自询问后进行的犯罪现场重演。首先，他们谈到了伊丽莎白·史蒂文斯的谋杀案。“你刚才对奥拉克兰侦探说，奥拉克兰侦探，”
that you were responsible for the murders of the three women. Is that correct? Just tell us in your own words, Paul, what happened in relation to the death of Elizabeth Stevens at Langwyne. I sort of got off the bus and I walked up behind her. Stuck my left hand around her. Banned her mouth like this and held her and I got her head right here. I started choking up with flames and she passed out after a while. Now I pulled out my knife and I dragged her to where she was sitting.
“你对这三名女性的谋杀负责。这是真的吗？保罗，用你自己的话告诉我们，关于伊丽莎白·史蒂文斯在朗瓦恩的死亡，发生了什么。”“我下了公交车，走到她身后。左手伸过去，像这样捂住她的嘴，抓住她，我把她的头按在这儿。我开始掐她的脖子，过了一会儿她就昏过去了。然后我掏出刀，把她拖到她坐的地方。”
Now I threw two branches on her body. Can you tell me why you attacked her on that night? I just, I just had, just had the feeling I saw her. What sort of feeling can you possibly describe when you had this feeling? Just wanted, just wanted to kill, just wanted to kill. The gun he describes wasn't a real gun, it was a fake pretend gun he had made himself at home. Paul also admitted to the attack on Rosa Toth. The detective said, what did you plan to do with Rosa?
“然后我在她尸体上扔了两根树枝。你能告诉我那天晚上你为什么要袭击她吗？”“我只是，我只是有那种感觉，我看到了她。”“当你产生这种感觉时，你能描述一下是什么样的感觉吗？”“就是想，就是想杀人，就是想杀人。”他描述的枪不是真枪，是他自己在家里做的假枪。保罗还承认了对罗莎·托斯的袭击。侦探问：“你打算对罗莎做什么？”
Paul said, I was just going to drag her in the park and kill her. That's all. He went on to say that when Rosa ran away, he caught the train from Seaford to Kananook. And not long after getting off the train, he saw Debbie Fremes getting out of her car at the shop. OK, can you tell us what happened here? Well, the car was sitting over there. This is Debbie Fremes car we're talking about. Yeah, the pole saw.
保罗说：“我只是想把她拖进公园杀了她。就这样。”他接着说，当罗莎逃跑时，他从西福德坐火车去了卡纳努克。下车后不久，他看到黛比·弗里姆从车里出来去商店。“好的，你能告诉我们这里发生了什么吗？”“嗯，车停在那边。我们说的是黛比·弗里姆的车。”“是的，保罗看到了。”
I was walking down this road here. Saw her jump out of the car. And it's the milk bar here. I jumped in the back seat of the car. And the car was directly across the road, so I could see her from inside the car in there. What caused you to select her, is it at that time? Just that go feeling. So what happened then?
“我沿着这条路走。看到她跳下车。那是这里的牛奶吧。我跳进了车的后座。车就在马路对面，所以我从车里能看到她在那儿。”“是什么让你在那时选择了她？”“就是那种感觉。”“那后来发生了什么？”
And then she came out. While I was crouched down, I got hear of footsteps coming from the class of the car. And she hopped in the car, but she didn't see me in the back. And she went to do a U-turn and pulled out the gun that I had. Just as she was doing that turn. She kept going straight into this wall. Paul then describes killing Fremes before detailing what happened after. I dragged her about a meter into the trees.
“然后她出来了。我蹲下时，听到从车那边传来的脚步声。她跳进车里，但没看到后座的我。她准备掉头，我掏出了我带的枪。就在她掉头的时候。她直接撞到了这堵墙上。”保罗随后描述了杀害弗里姆的过程，并详细说明了之后发生的事情。“我把她拖进树林里大约一米远。”
And she was lying against the fence. And I broke off two branches off the nearest tree. And I hopped back in the car again. I adjusted the seat to match my height. She was on smaller than me. And in the back madness street. Why the madness street? It wasn't too close, wasn't too far from home.
“她靠在栅栏上。我从最近的树上折了两根树枝。我又跳回车里。我调整了座位以适应我的身高。她比我矮。然后回到了马德斯街。为什么是马德斯街？”“离家不远也不近。”
He buried Debbie Fremes purse along the bike track where he later attacked Natalie Russell. He dug the purse up for detectives when they did the walkthrough of the crime scenes later on. When asked why he killed Debbie Fremes, his reply was, I just wanted to. Paul then details the murder of Natalie Russell. What can you tell me about this? I went up there earlier that day and cut the holes in the fences. When did you use to cut the holes in the fences?
他把黛比·弗里姆的钱包埋在自行车道旁，后来他在那里袭击了娜塔莉·拉塞尔。当侦探后来进行现场重演时，他把钱包挖了出来。当被问及为什么要杀黛比·弗里姆时，他的回答是：“我只是想杀。”保罗随后详细描述了娜塔莉·拉塞尔的谋杀案。“关于这个你能告诉我什么？”“我那天早些时候去过那里，在栅栏上剪了洞。你是什么时候剪的？”
Our suppliers. I stood here and watched Natalie Russell walk around the corner. And I went through this hole and waited behind the trees there. Until I saw a walk pass here and heading that way. And when she got about 10 metres down the track here, I came out of the fence. As we were walking along here, are you still maintaining that distance behind her? No, I was getting closer each time. I walked along the grass like this and made a sound.
“我们的供应商。我站在这里看着娜塔莉·拉塞尔绕过拐角。我穿过这个洞，在那边的树后等着。直到我看到她从这里走过去，往那边走。当她沿着小路走了大约10米时，我从栅栏里出来。”“当我们沿着这里走的时候，你还保持着跟在她后面的距离吗？”“不，我每次都靠得更近。我像这样走在草地上，发出声音。”
So you wouldn't be hurt? Yeah. I was armed with a red hand of knife. Where did that come from? In my place. Is it all you had? Just a red hand of knife. Oh, and a leather strap.
“这样你就不会被发现？”“是的。我带着一把红柄刀。”“那刀是从哪儿来的？”“在我家。那是你所有的东西吗？”“只有一把红柄刀。哦，还有一条皮带。”
You would have found it at the scene. Two pieces. What was that used for? Streamer. What was that for? It was a strap off a pair of addon to those later on. I grabbed it here around the mouth. Left hand, like this.
“你在现场找到的。两块。那是用来做什么的？”“带子。那是用来做什么的？”“那是后来加上的带子。我抓住她，像这样用左手捂住她的嘴。”
I dragged it through here. Which one do you want to cut it for? Same reason as before. No, I've always wanted to kill. Since when? Since I was about 14. After the murder, he walked back down the track towards his car, and he actually saw the police there checking it out.
“我把她拖到这里。你为什么要割开她的喉咙？原因和之前一样。不，我一直想杀人。”“从什么时候开始？”“从我大约14岁开始。”谋杀后，他沿着小路走回车边，甚至看到警察在那里检查。
He casually made his way out of the track and walked down Sky Road, away from the police. They were that close. As you can hear from the interviews, Paul displayed zero emotion and zero remorse. That never changed. He simply said he always wanted to kill, and was just waiting for the right opportunity.
他若无其事地离开小路，沿着天空路走开，避开了警察。他们离得那么近。正如你从询问中听到的那样，保罗表现出零情感和零悔意。这一点从未改变。他只是说他一直想杀人，只是在等待合适的时机。
As the interview was taking place, other police were searching his flat. They found a hat with blood on it, a large homemade knife, and a long cord with two knots tied at each end. The cord looked like it had hair on it. In his car, they found the fake gun he had made, another large knife, and a pair of pliers.
询问进行的同时，其他警察正在搜查他的公寓。他们发现了一顶沾有血迹的帽子、一把大型自制刀具，以及一根两端各打了一个结的长绳。绳子上看起来有头发。在他的车里，他们发现了那把自制的假枪、另一把大刀和一把钳子。
Each pair of pliers leaves a distinctive mark, much like a fingerprint, and they were able to later match the pair of pliers they found in Paul's car, as being the ones used to cut the hole in the fence at the crime scene of Natalie Russell. Remember back at the start of the story, Donna Vaines had a place breaking into, and her cats were killed.
每一把钳子都会留下独特的痕迹，就像指纹一样。他们后来能够将保罗车里发现的钳子与在娜塔莉·拉塞尔犯罪现场剪开栅栏的工具进行匹配。还记得故事开头，唐娜·维恩斯家被闯入，她的猫被杀了吗？
A death threat was written in blood on her wall. She then moved to a sister Trisha's place, and Trisha's neighbour Julia had also experienced a terrifying break-in, where her throat was cut in all of her photos, and her engagement dress was slashed. They were comforted by a male neighbour, who said whoever did it was a sicko, and he would look out for them.
墙上用血写着死亡威胁。她随后搬到了她姐姐翠莎家，翠莎的邻居朱莉娅也经历了一次可怕的入室抢劫，她所有照片里的喉咙都被割开了，订婚裙子也被划破了。他们得到了一个男邻居的安慰，他说做这件事的人是个变态，他会帮他们留意。
Well, that was Paul Daniel. He lived next door to Trisha Vaines. He admitted to committing both of those break-ins. He freely said that he went to Donna's place that night with the sole intention of killing her, but she wasn't home, so he killed her cats instead. The reason he gave, he hated Donna and Trisha. It was through Trisha, his neighbour, that he met Donna,
嗯，那个人就是保罗·丹尼尔。他住在翠莎·维恩斯隔壁。他承认犯下了那两起入室抢劫案。他坦率地说，那天晚上他去唐娜家，唯一的目的就是杀了她，但她不在家，所以他杀了她的猫。他给出的理由是，他讨厌唐娜和翠莎。正是通过他的邻居翠莎，他认识了唐娜，
and learnt that she was home alone most nights. That's why he targeted her. The reason why he hated them wasn't given. Donna was so fearful that she moved out of her unit, not realising she moved next door to the person responsible. The feelings obviously weren't mutual, because after Paul's arrest, this is what Trisha had to say. He was the nicest and most considerate person I ever met.
并得知她大多数晚上都独自在家。这就是他针对她的原因。他讨厌她们的原因没有说明。唐娜非常害怕，以至于搬出了她的公寓，却没意识到她搬到了肇事者的隔壁。这种感觉显然不是相互的，因为在保罗被捕后，翠莎是这样说的：“他是我见过最友善、最体贴的人。”
I could not believe it when I heard the news. I still find it difficult to accept. He was cool, calm and collected. He seemed quiet and subdued, and often kept to himself. Another one of Paul's neighbours had this to say. I just can't believe that the charges had been laid against him. He seemed the nicest of people. Paul Daniel was charged with three murders,
“听到这个消息时，我简直不敢相信。我至今仍难以接受。他冷静、沉着、镇定。他看起来安静而内敛，经常独来独往。”保罗的另一位邻居这样说：“我简直不敢相信他会被指控。他看起来是最友善的人。”保罗·丹尼尔被控三项谋杀罪，
Elizabeth Stevens, Debbie Freem and Natalie Russell. He was also charged with the abduction of Rosa Toth. Paul plead guilty, never trying to fight the charges. While awaiting sentencing, he was visited by many doctors and psychologists trying to find answers. What they found was that Paul Daniel was a rare breed of serial killer, murdering his victims at random without motive, simply because he had always wanted to.
分别是伊丽莎白·史蒂文斯、黛比·弗里姆和娜塔莉·拉塞尔。他还被控绑架罗莎·托斯。保罗认罪，从未试图抗辩。在等待判决期间，许多医生和心理学家拜访了他，试图寻找答案。他们发现保罗·丹尼尔是一种罕见的连环杀手，他随机杀害受害者，没有动机，仅仅是因为他一直想杀人。
He had always felt like killing, and he could no longer suppress his urges. He was able to describe his crimes without a flicker of emotion. They found him to be extremely emotionally disturbed, but not legally insane. He was diagnosed as having a sadistic personality disorder, demonstrated by a steady pattern of cruel, demeaning and aggressive behaviour since early adulthood.
他一直有杀人的冲动，再也无法抑制。他能毫无情感波动地描述自己的罪行。他们发现他情绪极其不稳定，但在法律上并不疯狂。他被诊断患有施虐型人格障碍，表现为自成年早期以来就有一贯的残忍、贬低和攻击性行为模式。
He appeared amused by the psychological and physical suffering he inflicted on his victims. There was in an interview with a psychologist that Daniel mentioned his favourite movie was a horror movie called The Stepfather, and that's where he got the idea to slash his victims' throats, because it seemed defective. Daniel did try and claim that one of his older brothers had sexually abused him when he was younger, but this claim was strongly denied by the brother and by his entire family.
他似乎对给受害者造成的心理和身体痛苦感到愉悦。在与心理学家的访谈中，丹尼尔提到他最喜欢的电影是一部叫《继父》的恐怖片，他就是从那里得到了割开受害者喉咙的想法，因为这看起来很有效。丹尼尔确实试图声称他的一位哥哥在他小时候对他进行过性虐待，但这一说法遭到了他哥哥及其全家人的强烈否认。
Daniel was sentenced in Melbourne's Supreme Court on the 20th of December 1993. He was given three life sentences with no parole period, the judge saying he was a danger to society for which nothing could be done. Daniel shared no remorse, and his only regret appeared to be the fact he was arrested. Eleven days later, Daniel lodged an appeal against his sentence on the grounds that it was excessive, and that the sentencing judge should have given him a minimum term of imprisonment. The appeal was heard in the Supreme Court in July 1994.
丹尼尔于1993年12月20日在墨尔本最高法院被判刑。他被判处三项终身监禁，不得假释，法官称他是对社会的一种威胁，对此无能为力。丹尼尔没有表现出任何悔意，他唯一的遗憾似乎是他被捕了。十一天后，丹尼尔以判决过重为由提出上诉，称判决法官应该给他一个最低刑期。上诉于1994年7月在最高法院审理。
Three judges heard the appeal, and they came to a majority verdict, two to one. Overruling the trial judge's decision, they granted Daniel a non-paral period of 30 years, meaning he could be released in seven years' time when he is 51 years old. When given his non-paral period, Daniel said, I will become a better person and I will not re-offend. That's my promise to God as well as to the people of Melbourne. But he still never said sorry for what he had done,
三名法官审理了此案，并以二比一的多数裁决。他们推翻了初审法官的决定，给予丹尼尔30年的不得假释期，这意味着他可以在七年后，即51岁时获释。当被告知他的不得假释期时，丹尼尔说：“我会成为一个更好的人，我不会再犯。这是我对上帝以及墨尔本人民的承诺。”但他仍然从未为自己的所作所为道歉，
or showed a shred of remorse. Daniel now identifies as a woman. Daniel has applied to have gender reassignment surgery. That request was rejected. Daniel has also applied to wear makeup and other beauty products in prison. That request was also rejected. Years later, Daniel wrote this in a letter from prison. I put the pieces together like this.
也没有表现出一丝悔意。丹尼尔现在认同自己为女性。丹尼尔已申请进行性别重置手术。该请求被拒绝。丹尼尔还申请在狱中使用化妆品和其他美容产品。该请求也被拒绝。多年后，丹尼尔在狱中写道：“我把这些碎片拼凑起来是这样的：”
A. Born feeling like the other sex. B. Growing up interested in female things. C. Fearing adulthood as a male. D. Having to suppress my feelings. E. Committing these crimes to try to destroy those feelings. F. Living now with the acceptance of those feelings. Daniel continues, I committed those disgusting crimes not because I ever hated woman kind,
“A. 出生时就感觉自己是另一种性别。B. 成长过程中对女性事物感兴趣。C. 害怕以男性身份进入成年期。D. 不得不压抑自己的感受。E. 犯下这些罪行是为了试图摧毁那些感受。F. 现在接受了这些感受。”丹尼尔继续写道：“我犯下那些令人作呕的罪行，不是因为我恨女性，
but because I never really felt that I was male. Unfortunately for me, I used the word hate when police interviewed me. Because hate was the only emotion I thought could correctly identify with my confused identity. In 2012, Daniel was interviewed by police in relation to four prison rapes that had occurred on fellow inmates. No charges ever followed from what I've been able to find. Daniel had experienced the urge to kill from a young age. Just 14 years old. And had been following women around for years.
而是因为我从未真正觉得自己是男性。不幸的是，当警察审问我时，我用了‘恨’这个词。因为我认为‘恨’是唯一能准确识别我混乱身份的情感。”2012年，丹尼尔因涉及四起针对狱友的强奸案而接受了警方询问。据我所知，此后从未提出过指控。丹尼尔从小就有杀人的冲动。年仅14岁。并且多年来一直跟踪女性。
Just waiting for the right time. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
只是在等待合适的时机。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。